[Music]
hello everyone welcome to job assist
webinar on future and carrier for
charities in digital marketing so this
is priyanka your host for the session if
I am audible loud and clear to all
please respond with a yes in the chat
box great I can see few quick responses
in the chat box perfect perfect so once
again I would like to welcome you all in
this webinar so we have our you know the
concerned person and the street is there
who is heading this job is this program
and simply learn
so I'll just hand it over to her and
she'll guide you that how you can make
use of this program which is provided by
simply learn to get ahead into your
carriers
okay so Heine screen and I order this to
you hi Priyanka am i audible yes
mistress
you are arguing so much dying over to
your yoga thank you thanks Priyanka hi
everyone a very good afternoon to all of
you I'm miss Reed having table this
program and simply alone I welcome you
all to our job Asus program and I'm
really happy to see more and more
candidates joining online thanks man
meat
thanks entrance good afternoon winnowed
but afternoon everybody
it's so good to see you all online and I
think that today's session or I would
say webinar is the biggest example how
we are going to total in fact I would
say that when we are taking the courses
online we just want to relax sit at our
places learn more and more as much
possible as we can and if we have
already crawled our College lives I
would say and the term that is tall's
for now is Millennials that they are
more into digital an 84 percent of
approximate time that we devote on our
mobiles and laptops I think we cannot
escape that the first thing that I would
say is that I always say that the very
beginning of webinars that I host in
weekends is that I am really really
lucky that the trainers Dementors the
guest speakers accept my request to come
online on afternoons in weekends and I
think it is really really difficult
because they are quite busy with their
schedule and then to manage to come
online just to take further a kind of
step in which they can guide they can
suggest all the candidates how they can
cause his career in a particular
technology is really really am I feel so
thankful and I am really really thankful
to run up Eric today I think some of you
are already attending his sessions he is
one of the best trainer who is taking
digital marketing with us and I'm really
thankful to run up today for his
presence online on weekend of course he
will guide you how exactly you can move
ahead with digital marketing because it
is the heartbeat of today's generation
and I would say that nowadays
traditional marketing or traditional
advertisements do not impress us that
much and we are more inclined towards
checking out each and everything online
and even like food till it's prom food
to learning each and every
we do in a digital way so and I think
that all of you who are taking up the
cause or who actually want to make their
career in digital marketing or the
digital era of course there is a
progress only and success only path
because the full world is going online
so we will be having more and more
opportunities in digital era so I
welcome planners I pronounced thank you
so much Provenza Brenner for giving your
time coming online on weekend I know
it's really I just feel that you accept
my request and you can't came online
it's like really really thankful to you
and all of us will be learning a lot
today because even I wanted to a change
the station and I wanted to learn more
that how I can also check it out how to
go digital when I'm not from a technical
background but I think that most of the
guys who are not even from technical
background can also catch up with
digital marketing and they can also make
a career in the same thanks a lot in the
street for your warm welcome and indeed
it's my pleasure to help through
students and anyone who is interested
and going forward with learning digital
marketing it's always a pleasure to be a
part of simply learn in this format of
webinars as well as in their training
programs and it's my revered honor to
that I would be able to help out
students apart from training while I try
to do and incorporate this elements
whenever I am taking my batches as well
about how best you can reap the benefits
of this boom of digital marketing and
it's good that simply learn has provided
this specific wonderful platform in the
form of job assist which is a unique and
really important element which every
training organization should be
providing which just just does not stop
with the student learning the course and
completing it there but taking the
journey forward part the course also or
while they are attending the course
wherein they are taking that kind of
responsibility or trying to help out the
students to reap the best benefits even
for
learning experience so that's something
nice from the end of simply learn and
it's my pleasure to be a part out here
thank you so much for today exactly I
just want to get you through our the
agenda that what all we are going to
cover today so as Pranab is there he'll
be actually taking you through what
exactly is digital marketing because we
do have some of the candidates online
who have just got enroll in the course
and some of the people like me who are
not from the technical background and
who would like to learn more so I think
that I would like to start from scratch
and digital marketing domains of course
like in which particular domains you can
become export and if I would say that
everybody will be having some or the
other expertise level and they would
like to make their career in a
particular domain of digital marketing
because it is expanding and I think that
every day we are adding one or the other
domain in digital marketing era so it is
one of the thing and then we can discuss
about how to be a digital marketing
leader I would say that again like I
don't know but I have this habit of
repeating it again I began because I do
have one um partner with me today and we
are really really lucky to have him all
line because it was really it became
really difficult for me to reach him
even he took some of the interviews and
they become a partner of our jobs
program also and they took some some
interviews in Delhi and it was really
difficult for me to reach out to him
just because he has now he is now in
Indonesia and we have some time
differences well but I am really
thankful to Rohan that he accepted my
request and he could manage coming
online for an hour so we are really
lucky that he is online and he will be
actually taking you through the market
trend he can talk about something very
beneficial that is salary structure and
then the career options that you can
offer so I I think today as we all are
online we are going to get much out of
this session so
think Rohan is also online drone can you
hear me
okay I think that will take some time to
come come online and we can start it
with all of you together because we have
many candidates waiting now welcome you
all again and runner over to you thank
you so much Shona speed thanks a lot
okay so a very warm welcome and really
nice to have you people you're in this
particular job assist webinar brought
through in the opportunity related to
digital marketing by simply learn before
I go ahead and discuss the coder
elements let me have a quick check
everyone is able to you mean loud and
clear please respond through the chat
box
great so with that being seen from many
of you let me get started with a few of
the basics that we are going to learn in
this program so before I start on as
being a trainer it's my habit to discuss
and talk a lot out here but today's
webinar let me be very frank is more of
things coming from your end means we
will be going forward and seeing through
elements related to a lot of stuff about
digital and the complete element or the
era of how jobs could be done you know
how you could acquire your dream job or
what are the parameters for the same but
with that being said definitely it's
more going to be your inputs which are
going to be important in this complete
webinar so time in the head I'll be
asking you through about the elements
which you would like to add on from your
end so with that being said of course
quick set of introduction about myself
many of you who are a part of my
training program have definitely been
knowing about my background for others
who are participating for the very first
time I myself trained up run of Perak
and enthusiastic digital marketer who
has been in this field for eight plus
years and I have explored all different
entities and elements of digital
marketing which you generally see
through in your course where or which
you generally see through as a part and
parcel of your non class activity itself
there in there are these entities like
SEM PPC Google AdWords display
advertising social media marketing so on
and so forth so mostly you name it and I
would have done that in digital
marketing together with that I myself
Google AdWords search Google Adwords
a google video and Google Analytics
certified I have managed entity like
campaigns of over 1 CR value in paid
campaigns we are going to see what they
are in the course have managed analytics
traffic of over 1.5 million monthly
users have managed social media
strategies of campaigns running in
hundreds of thousand dollar value on a
yearly basis and together with that on
the training end I have been in the
training field for over populace years
have trained more than 1500 2000
students through online marketing in the
form of webinars and in the form of
methodology we are connecting apart from
that classroom training copper training
and other entities at as well so that's
a brief background about what I have
been doing in case if anyone of you is
interested in knowing further details
you could connect with me anytime on
LinkedIn on the domain lynda.com slash
in slash connect tube tunnel so that's
my vanity URL or that's the URL which I
am available on LinkedIn indeed so then
you could check through more details of
my profile with that being said before
starting in with the entity of the other
elements which we are going to learn
about job assist I like to know through
indeed three important things from your
end first of all definitely your name is
there visible in the chat box so you
could start in with your name followed
by that I want to know through your
background means most of you if you are
a professional than your professional
background or if someone is a student
then their education background in terms
of mostly the experience in terms of
maybe the industry you are currently
working and most importantly apart from
this I am interested to know through as
to when you are a part of this job
assist webinar definitely you have some
back-end thoughts from your end
as to what you are looking forward at
means someone may be looking from
position perspective like I want to be a
manager or I want to be maybe start on
as an intern anything like that some of
you may be having certain thoughts in
relation with
what particular skill I want to build
myself means anyone is looking forward
to be a web analyst or someone is
looking forward probably to be an SEO
expert so these are some stuff which
maybe some of you may be having in your
background so I want your you to share
this element with me through the chat
box as to your background name and stuff
and if in case if you have something
like this in your mind that I am looking
for a career as being an SEO specialist
or I am looking for a career in
e-commerce please then let me know
through so as while I am taking the
points I could help on with certain tips
regarding the same so please use the
chat box and help me with the details
regarding this and then I'll start on
with the next slide to share on with you
people
you
you
so let's see who initiates the chat
first because that is like when you are
going for an interview also there is the
person who is false of course come first
serve is going to be the rule okay so
here we have gunshot who is the business
analyst with ten years experience in
banking and Quality Assurance looking to
start a blog or a blog as well as he is
looking for more in the venture of
e-commerce great then there is challenge
who is done his MBA and graduate but
have hands-on experience on blogging
social media and has his own blog great
children's really nice to know that I
also started my first blog
when was I I was just in college in
class 11 then there is Raj who has
graduated looking to help a startup with
digital marketing skills he has great
nice to know that Raj then there is
Mukund who is pursuing PG DVM and has
experience of almost over a year in
sales and looking forward for a career
as a strategist wonderful nice to know
that local and then via who is the
business BD manager in corporate travel
industry and what is he looking forward
at with two years experience great then
there is a Bechet then there is Channel
pan who is a business manager with a
Louisville News experience wonderful in
office automation and one to have
expertise in content marketing that
would really help your business which in
the van or the company where you are a
part of then there is the via who wants
to be specifically a digital marketing
specialist unchilled
15 months experience an IT sector
looking to start on as SEO experts will
are unsure that will be really nice
because your IP experience would help
you there Mundy who is having five point
five years international sales and
marketing experience and looking to
expand career so together with the
industry do product engineering and IT
looking to add on the part of digital as
well and abyss shake he is in corporate
strategy and business analytics nice to
know that abhi shake mo heads again from
business development background looking
to have his own startup bunkered 16
years experience in wireless in telecom
and looking for intrapreneurship option
because great with this MBA with two
years experience working for SAS as an
area seals looking forward to work as
web analyst and content marketing nice
to know that message and Vivek is
working in real estate with sales
followed by
Lakshmi with Athenians experience and
freelancing rush means Western a BTech
then moneyed with three years experience
looking for digital strategies Nana who
is a blogger looking for e-commerce SEO
diksha who the fresher someone wants to
be a specialist great so that's really
in detail profiles of many of you we
know having 11 players experience and
what I could see through their a trainer
who is a journalist and want to switch
full-time digital from operations and
stuff to God as well as rush me who
wants to own her own business
great so three set of people which I
could broadly classify in the set
followed by lastly yes also who is
looking for opportunities past college
so
lot of queries lot of backgrounds let me
toss a fire with the elements which you
people have shared majority of you are
looking for from the perspective of job
majority or many are looking forward for
a full switch also means they are in a
particular field like probably sales or
they are an IT or maybe operations and
they want to go forward and do it in
terms of fully digital some of you are
looking for an add-on profile means you
are settled in your profiles in maybe
marketing which is traditional mostly or
maybe some elements in IT and you want
an profile of marketing plus digital or
maybe I T plus digital as a part of it
so that's another entity who is your in
the part of the seminar the third one
are those who are looking at probably
few intrapreneurship opportunities
specifically in terms of job or business
opportunities means they are settled in
their career but they want to start
something add on additionally so that's
something nice to know on and if I
talked about the perspective of the kind
of positions many are looking at some
are looking at being a strategist or
some are looking forward at being indeed
an analyst and some are even looking at
expert position and stuff like that so
it's a mix whole set of background we
are having and if I talk about the
experience level it's mostly from
pressures up to people with eleven years
or plus experience and apart from this
there is one more entity who is looking
at being a freelancer or who is looking
forward at owning something online so
that's working online on their own maybe
as a start-up or maybe as an individual
and what all are the opportunities for
that so that's something really
interesting because I have also spared
good amount of time in my career in
working for
these kind of opportunities in
freelancing or consulting and other
stuff so with that being said and this
whole plethora being known from our end
let us take through the part out here as
to what all is the opportunity is
available and how we can and benefit
from the same so if you want to break it
down in terms of major verticals like
what all other opportunities available
then apart from social media which is
something commonly known here is a
vertical base breakdown about what all
other opportunities we're in in web and
detailing that's one of the opportunity
wherein you can consider social media as
a part of it ecommerce sort retailing as
a part of it and other domains then
there is SEO out here in the second
element I believe will I ninety percent
or I can say almost 99 percent most of
you have been a part of the digital
marketing force or are away knowing the
basics about all of these I'll be giving
a short explanation but I believe all of
you are aware about the full form and
are well versed with terms like SEO or
analytics so SEO is the second domain
being shown here followed by analytics
and then there are these three domains
at the bottom all verticals which are
there in the form of paid traffic
affiliate marketing and e-commerce so
before diving into the I can say the
related entities in all of them I would
like to first give you a kind of
assessment which is to be done on a self
end basis so when people ask me this
specifically from people who are looking
at switching or from the perspective of
full time opportunity there is some kind
of first skill enhancement or some kind
of skill judgment which you need to
from your end itself like you need to be
aware about what is the best thing you
like in if you want to choose one out of
the given options so if your element is
more about creativity and you are
someone from your own personality
perspective who likes fun who is a bit
of extra world and has an habit of
sharing then probably positions which
are related to social media are really
good for you
in terms of the job profile there would
be playing around updating or posting
would be playing around letting people
know about your products or services
would be playing around creating content
which is having elements of a lot of fun
stuff many times like you make something
in the form of photos which are
interesting for people or mostly there
is something known as memories or memes
which you would be knowing so if that is
your personality this is one of the best
jobs to get started with if you are
someone who is really good at numbers or
who likes reports and stuff like that
who likes to always think on the back
end working process of something then
for you position related to web analyst
or data analyst are something which are
really useful because therein you are
going to again play with the same thing
of analyzing and stuff like that on the
other hand if you have a mix of both of
these means you are a bit good at
creativity also plus you are good at
evil analysis and numbers then positions
related to paid stuff that is probably
doing paid ads which would be calling
from all entities right from paid ads on
search engine all paid ads on social
media or even other display advertising
platforms all of them would be
a part and parcel around the same so
they're in unique creativity in form of
ad creation in form of for knowing what
works best
what does not and on the other hand when
you get the results through the paid
activities you have done you need to
work on and have an idea even about the
you
hello Brenner are you there we cannot
hear you Ranas the audio is missing from
your side sorry everybody I'm just
trying to connect with runner offline
just give me a minute which are sorry
Brenner we couldn't - here you are so if
you can just repeat because there was
some audio issue for a minute or so so
if you can just repeat I'm sure sure I
need even I saw that so I paused on at
that moment itself oh yeah
so what I was telling is if there is
creativity and analysis both of with
which you are talented then paid ads or
going in that field is something really
nice where you analyze numbers you
analyze the output which is coming to
you plus you have the creativity in form
of our creation as well apart from it if
you're someone who likes the element of
maybe content or like the element of
creativity plus you are a bit having an
ish for even I can say technical skills
not necessary like being a hardcore
coder but understanding basics really
well like our website works or what is
the backend through which there is
operations happening and you are
interested in even numbers together then
I can save profile like SEO is really
good because it has some battened
activities involved mostly as a part of
the profile not specifically to be done
by you but to have the understanding of
that activity plus it has the element of
content creation as a part of it and it
is a really nice profile to work on -
apart from this in case you are someone
who is more of I can say business minded
and this is an opportunity which could
be falling both ways you like to handle
on just not the operations which happen
online but you are even interested in
the elements which eyes working offline
from at least the knowledge perspective
like how does an online order happen or
what is the backend process once we have
bought a product on Amazon so how is
that cycle of supply chain management
working in plus how is the complete
operations also working in terms of
integrating a payment gateway or maybe
how is a login account being created how
are good images being taken of the
product so if you are someone who wants
to mix both of this you can either try
out for your own venture which many of
you have been asking about in terms of
being an entrepreneur in the e-tailing
or e-commerce industry or as an
effective of job you could try out for
positions specifically in the e-commerce
vertical so this is the kind of basic
bifurcation which I would say is to be
done coming from your end in terms of
what is something you are really good at
or what is something which you assess
yourself or believe that you are looking
forward act
apart from this or if I talk of a long
term prospective means maybe if you are
looking at specifically from a job
perspective of the future scope in five
years or ten years there you would be
having two kind of opportunities with
you one would be in the form of you
become a specialist in one particular
field means you start with today with as
an SEO executor for example and you go
forward over the period of time and work
on the entities of the elements like
being an SEO manager past three years
and then going over and even deed on the
position of probably an SEO specialist
or you can say a SEO strategist which
could be coming around spice
plus years down the line so they tell me
one kind of profile like this which you
can look forward at or on a longer time
frame of five to ten years you could be
most of you would also be interested
having a profile which is kind of a mix
of all of this because over a period of
time you will be having experience of
bits and pieces in almost all of those
entities so there you could be growing
with positions like starting as a
digital marketing intern or maybe years
executed then growing on to a digital
marketing manager and then going on to
something like head of marketing or head
of digital marketing and stuff like that
so these are also options which are
spread in the industry depending on your
talent pool as to what you can go
forward and do through so that's a brief
background which I want to share in
regards with this particular slide where
there is the verticals being shown and
lastly yes for many people who are
looking at probably freelancing or
specifically who are looking at owning
online we have this element of affiliate
marketing as well so couple of you
people who would have completed your
DMCA course or would be in your course
would be having a brief know-how about
it for anyone who does not have a know
how about what is affiliate marketing
let me give you an idea about the same
specifically for people who are in this
category of earning on time or want to
be a freelancer they're in depending on
the skills and talents you have if you
have the ability to probably market and
sell products online or maybe even not
specifically products maybe services
online you can do that with the help of
affiliate marketing now to give you a
very plain example of affiliate
marketing let's say that there is a
friend of yours who is looking
to buy a flat and you are yourself a
real estate agent who has some other
connections who are also looking forward
at selling a flag so in this kind of
entity there are three people involved
there is one who is the flag seller whom
you are knowing there is one who is the
agent or broker or consultant in between
and there is one who is a flag buyer so
you're the person in the form of agent
he is neither the owner of the product
or he is neither the one who is actually
the person investing money but he is
technically just acting as a connector
between the flag seller and the flag
buyer and if he does this activity
successfully he earns an Commission so
this is the same concept which is there
or if you just take this concept online
means you create a platform online with
the help of which you are able to go
forward and be that connector in between
you can earn a commission or you are
able to go forward and probably having
through skills because all these skills
could be used for acting or becoming a
connector so that's one more interesting
field which is available for people who
are looking at probably the buzzword
which many times it's heard on money
online so this is one of the interesting
activities which is possible with the
help of affiliate marketing and that's
the same thing being shared out here as
well that in terms of the variety of
scopes which I see there is SEO like I
said wherein you have your technical
element plus your element of bit of
creativity that is paid media or paid
campaigns where you are creative plus
you like numbers as well there is
analytics wherein you are
only going forward on the part of
numbers then there is social media and
video marketing wherein you have
creativity fun you are an extra world
you can pick up the camera and speak in
front of it and the other is also apart
from it one more element which there are
independent profiles sometimes around it
and sometimes it's a joint profile of
even email marketing so urine again if
you have creativity skills and you have
analysis ability apart from social media
and PPC and stuff like that you could be
working on email marketing as well where
you use your creativity for creating
nice set of emails and apart from this
you use your analytical elements for
analyzing the results through them so
these are the various [ __ ] and stuff
which is there in relation with the
fields out here apart from it there are
lot more details which are there right
from your salary structure right from
how to go forward and being a great
leader so this is something which is I
can say better done then side rather
than better said than done because you
each of these activities are always
going to have your challenges and this
is something which is going to be a
bigger I can say kind of iceberg in
front of you wherein you have to break
that iceberg and go on the other side so
you won't be having the challenge of
your experience from sales and now you
have to move to digital or your
experience from IT and now to do
something different so there all these
entities are going to be a part and
parcel like to share with you my
real-time story an example I started my
first affiliate marketing based website
to earn money online almost in 2006
almost a decade ago where someone of my
friend told me that you can earn money
online by putting ads on your blog and I
tried it and I because of not having all
these four entities
in part and partial as well as not
having a guided approach to it I feel
very soon I closed my blog within just
three months so first let me tell you
that whenever there is a shift or a
change happening in any prospective
there is great amount of challenges
which will come as a part and parcel
there are great amount of difficulties
which would be a part of it
but if you have focused of maybe if you
have failed in three interviews and you
want to crack the fifth one or you have
failed in maybe two assessment tests and
you want to crack the third one
definitely one would be growing on the
part of a being a great digital
marketing leader and with that being
said I think it's over to you for any
specific questions or else then we'll be
having a group partner from Omnicom
media to help you through people with
more insights about the same so that's
the model part from my in which I want
to share about matching your assessment
with your skills and would be awaiting
if there is anything specific with you
people would like to know through
or else I think we could help through
with the further part being taken
forward from here
here enough thank you so much run of
actually I think that it is the first
thing for me I have actually deep dived
into what exactly we can passive with
the kids all the interests like I always
say this thing that we all who are
getting more and more used to the
digital devices that we have and we as I
say that maximum of our time goals on
laptops or mobiles but still it depends
upon the interest of a particular person
and today is the day when I actually
know that if I am enjoying like what
exactly I enjoy and still it is
available for me to explore more because
in digital marketing domains we do have
so many of different areas as you
explain that according to my interests I
can take up that particular area and I
can become an expert in that I should
not say that because the getting expert
is not at all possible in this changing
and ever demanding era because each and
everything like every day something new
is coming online but I think that some
people might be having some questions so
as I'm saying we are really lucky to
have run Evandro and with us today if
you have any questions please do ping on
charge so that Pranav can address all
your questions okay Sabrina we have got
some of the questions here in any chat
if you can take that yeah so let me take
them McCune says I want to know how to
start if I am aiming for a strategist
rule okay so move on here and let me be
very frank enough if you want to start
on with a strategist rule you need to
have at least some good amount of
hands-on exposure what I mean by
hands-on exposure is you should have sit
down yourself and maybe manage the
campaign wherein you have done spend of
more than one lakh or more than PI lakhs
and you have not just done that on one
day but you have done it for a minimum
timeframe of two to three years plus if
you are going forward and straight
forward starting with being a strategist
I think it would be a challenging
activity because at the end of
it just has to know the part of
execution or I can say a strategist is
someone who is almost an expert on the
execution level himself so you have
people under you who are executing you
executing it but you yourself should
have done that for some time in your
career if that is not then I would
rather suggest first get some hands-on
time with execution and then think to go
forward for a strategist or the Nana
says can an e-commerce site with
affiliation links have Google ads on it
if I also do blogging on it then I
indeed you could do that but you are
spoiling your own business because you
want your main aim when you are creating
an e-commerce website is to sell
products and at that time when you go
forward and put ads the ads could be of
other e-commerce players who want to
sell their product so it's not a
suggested method to do this so you could
be having an e-commerce site
specifically selling their own products
or maybe even affiliating means Amazon
has that ability you can be an affiliate
partner with them so that is good but I
would say a specific no for Google ads
that's not something for a ecommerce
website yes if you have a blog Google
ads could be the best thing for it then
when I says is programmatic advertising
fine as a career nice question winner
winner so you're in this set when I
discuss about creativity plus technical
back-end in that specifically if you are
good at I can say operations plus you
are good ad to some technical element
means you understand how code and stuff
works and back in then I think
programmatic is the best thing because
Operations is the major factor which
plays a role in programmatic so if that
is something you are really looking
forward at you could go for programmatic
it's a really nice field in D then
siddharth says I am currently working on
feeding mesh so what makes that
and cpa's leash and looking for more
that works out and affiliates that
definitely that's a good field to go
forward with now because it's a rising
field highly there so you could stick to
that if you are looking for other
elements if you talk about in
specifically CPS based entities I could
say you could dive in in the finance
sector because there are lot of pin tech
services like loans and insurance and
all of them which could help you in your
affiliate work process or you could even
dive in in the e-commerce sector there
are tons of players who have websites
and products related to comparison
websites or related to giving reviews of
a product or service and that helps them
to get on to the part of owning good
affiliate commissions so that's
something apart from your current
English you can work on siddhart
how do I start making career as a
strategist and also how do we define
skills in terms of DM what are the terms
so nice question one me so anytime if
you have been to LinkedIn or if you
create your profile on LinkedIn or even
other platforms like nori dot-com
monster comments any other job site in
your profile you have an option of
skills which is there so I am on my
profile I'll share that or show it to
you right away
in there is a specific option where you
can add on the skills from your end so
like here you can see a link of add a
new skill and in this if you go forward
and search for skills so all of the
skills which were there mentioned in the
presentation like SEO like I have
already added SEO so it's not coming
there so you have something like off
page SEO sending like SEO or even if you
name it as probably SEM or paid ads that
would be also a part so these are the
major skills like paid media or paid
contents it's a huge list as well when
depending on your know-how you can
define the
same in your profiles so at a minimum if
I want to say all the stuff which we
have shown in the presentation right
from SEM - maybe SEO - even content
marketing so on and so forth they would
be a part and parcel or they would be
the next best match depending on your
look look out for then for a fresher it
would be better to intern or startup as
DM executed with the DM agency or other
companies a really nice question
shatranj so it depends on the
opportunity you are getting if you are
getting an opportunity of an executing
it's definitely better than an intern
because it gives more responsibility to
you now if you talk about working with
an agency or a company in that element I
would say it depends on the kind of your
personal management skills if you are
looking forward at working on many
projects at one go then you should be
thinking of going in an agency because
there there would be any new client from
any new industry right from insurance to
real estate or anything coming like that
but if you are looking forward at
probably being an expert in one
particular industries like you want to
gain more knowledge of digital marketing
in real estate industry then it would be
better to search out for job in a
company so it all depends on what you
are looking forward at agency climate is
a bit considerably more challenging in a
relation with an individual company so
that's how it goes forward so what role
should I start I have hands on during my
project I handle a website social media
but that was four four four five months
so best thing locally you could start in
with position like digital marketing
assistant manager or maybe digital
marketing associate and stuff like that
and get hands-on as you have already
mentioned you know three to four
entities you can get hands-on with these
position four over one or one and a half
year and then start with freelance
consulting first where you
consult couple of businesses if you get
a good hand held in that much timeframe
you can then work on full time as a
digital marketing strategist or
consultant for sure then
[Music]
what is the detail scope in analytics
well if it's mostly about numbers and it
is about getting the people means
getting decisions to the company of how
they can improve themselves so it's
numbers and the improvisation which is
the major scope there how to start a
career which I think that's answered you
can start as an intern or start as an
executive the means if I tell frankly
first you do your assessment but
secondly it's also on the part of the
company to help you out with what kind
of skill you will best suited to as a
working professional how can we have
skills as I would be changing what all
things we can show to recruiter so this
is the best thing I suggest is if you
can get in some part-time internship
opportunity or even we have the stupid
proof platform which many of you are
work on past your DMCA course so even
there and when you have done even
stimulation based campaigns it's more
than enough for getting started with a
base level or a junior profile if
someone is looking for senior profile
then it would be a concern of having
heavy hands-on experience mostly the
dmca course and the stimulation part in
the stew control lab is more than enough
for putting the right skills in your
career and then passing through the job
interview
rusick it definitely depends on what you
show on your profile it's it's possible
that companies may consider it and you
could go forward and start on with it so
it depends a lot on the part of how you
are going forward with it it can be
challenging but yet there is a
possibility if you have certain
certifications it helps a lot
apart from what you are currently doing
also many of you are there are few
common queries around sales and stuff so
many of you who are having good
experience in sales I would definitely
suggest that you could even work on the
profile of something which is related to
BDM or client servicing but instead of
sales it would be more on the part of
digital so most of the agencies have
this wonderful profile which gives you a
back-end of both you have your sales
background Plus you are now getting some
hands-on and DM as well as you are now
on the card of understanding the backend
of DM in a better manner so many of you
who are in sales and want to shift
through I would say instead of doing a
pure switch a client servicing profile
and digital would be of more usefulness
to you
that name that I don't think there is a
huge concern because you have seven
years content experience and operations
and new media so I think for your
scenario I would rather suggest that you
go in for positions like digital
marketing strategist' or export or maybe
at least digital marketing manager
rather than starting something as it is
SEO executor because if you have at
least some relevant industry experience
like Continental and new media that's
more than enough for giving you the
switch I would not suggest with seven
plus years experience to go in as an SEO
executor the way I believe I have
answered that that this would be the
best thing for you to start on with da
Marina yes I would see I would suggest
you that if you are just means I am not
knowing your background but I would
suggest before starting the full fledge
agency you work on for at least six
months or so in an agency that could be
one thing or second you find a partner
with you where's experience of minimum
three five years plus and digital so if
someone like who has been full-time or
had some agency experience would like to
partner with you go forward and get
together decide on your commercials and
other elements and then you can work on
the same that would be better off for
telecom profession with 12 plus what
role do you suggest part that would be
best that in your own organization if
you can get an internal switch and with
so much of experience definitely you
could be going on more positions related
to like a marketing head which has part
of this digital as well
cool so with that being said I've tried
to answer many of the elements around
that there are some more stuff around
career options and more and there is
Rohan out here to assist you with the
same so the space would be really good
if you could go ahead and
let the room will be a part of it sharp
enough thank you so much for enough
thank you and I think that most of the
questions that are remaining also I
believe Ron will be able to take that
and thank you so much pranaam it was
really fantastic and I think it is the
first webinar for me in which I have
learned a lot because even now I know as
it is going to be like really beneficial
for us to refer this particular webinar
after this also and i i i will be making
sure that i can upload this particular
webinar on youtube and provide the link
to all of you because now I can see the
breakup as well as this is the first
showing for me that I can see the
breakup as as per the interest that what
all domains we can opt for and as per
the career options yes I think that Ron
will be able to take each and everything
on that part thank you so much run out
thank you thank you for being online and
thank you for accepting my request on
weekend coming online and giving us so
many insights thank you so much enough
thanks Pete my pleasure indeed
thanks thanks Burnham hello everyone so
a crucial part again I would say a one
particular very much influential thought
and the most learning part is done from
run of and the crucial part in virtual
actually see that how I am going to move
forward after the course or what all
career options are there how much I can
expect out of the market or what are the
market trends line thank you so much
Rohan for your presence today and I know
it is the time difference to you have
matched up with it thank you so much and
I I think that we can just transfer the
present day access to Rohan Priyanka you
there yes the street I have given the
the present drex's to Rohan thank you so
much thank you Ryoga okay
okay ah hey guys welcome to this webinar
times none of our taking most of the
questions really good I would agree the
most of them but yes some of the things
a I guys are mostly common questions
from all of you around how can you
change your fields how can you start
with the you know digital marketing
journey I guess most of you are already
aware about about this course in in in
in some aspects of it like but also
mention about paid media affiliates seu
and then some of the others other of
appeals they're all part of digital
marketing so anyone you pick up it's all
digital to be social be search be mobile
with shopping with video so when when I
say digital marketing it includes almost
everything that when you do an internet
when you go to your smart phones when
you go to any digital device it's all
digital ads that you see there so when
we say that the word digital marketing
itself is a thin line between digital
marketing and advertising collaborate
within this book first to get before a
person into the website like tons Times
of India and they meaty an ad or we are
on Facebook and we see a right-hand side
ad so multiple formats multiple devices
and it's all are interrelated
it's a beautiful journey that you
started off pillar you're in sales or
you're in any other field it's it's very
related
Hey hey guys who so we'll start so I've
been part of Omicron group and the
I do a little bit of fighting as well
and I got on touch with Rishi in
regarding by you know hiding pressures
so we'll what do we expect when somebody
is interviewing and who do go to the
characters which which which we need
when I particularly higher so currently
you know I like Nikki mentioned so I
moved to Jakarta so I'm gonna be based
out of Malaysia so again the county
remains the same so I'm still working
with only comedian group I am basically
head of programmatic flag walking one of
you was asking about a couple of
questions around programmatic also to
see our own one person talking in in in
that or even asking about it so what
exactly is programmatic I'll answer that
so it's it's basically you know an
automated fashion of you know buying and
selling of media so in our to buy ads on
Times of India or after buying ads on
and sometimes I can actually try their
contacting their sales people I can
track directly by it by us platform
which Google has made which which others
the likes of TDD medium asks a lot of
other platforms and tools I've eaten
before that I was with Accenture I was a
trainer there working with Google train
a lot of people I have spend a lot of
money of my brands which becomes luggage
feed and all this on Cisco into Puma
Puma and then before that when I was
just beginning my career even I started
with a very small agency and the
experience really nice very working on
small agency because the a pad for a
time you get to learn everything so when
I say everything is starting from your
so charged to a CEO through analytics
and almost everything so with small my
name's
detour is that you user mode with more
money the tools that you use are less
but that's that's the downside out for
Norfolk are you please
because because what you do when you
work in a bigger organization is that
the tools are capable enough in order
for less manpower and more tools that
you know they can take and give us the
results back so the likes of Adobe
Omniture which is fantastic will if you
use it it can give you you know amazing
insights and analytics in terms of what
is the behavior of your audience which
is coming on your website what do they
do how much time do they spend for pages
do the browse through all of that when
we get as an information as a big data
and then we analyze it and then going to
show you an spaces that so you might
have seen that
the other the name of the tool is Adobe
Omniture click on the check
om ni ture on the top
I think it's the subtleties not on
placards okay um yep so the advertising
industry trends a little bit about which
industry you're in
so we are basically going inside
advertising agency or or in in general
about marketing so you already know that
TV radio newspaper magazine cinema
outdoor PR all present before you know
couple of decades when they for you an
internet started all of these mediums
were already there they are still there
in the market leg India they still they
are still very big chunk of money that
goes into TV all that goes into or you
know newspapers so you still see a big
chunk of money going into newspapers and
and into you know distress of the media
but digital is growing and it's Israeli
picking up and with the likes of T
monetization and digital India all of
that of us we all have started using you
know payment or payment ATMs and payment
ups which makes it even more users going
on and then si users and talking about
tier 2 tier 3 cities people like where
we eat our food people like who give a
scooter who who service odd maids are
our workers whose guys are also ATM so
imagine will be the number of smartphone
penetration that has happened in the
country because of it digital is also
going to pick up because your users are
present on digital you have users or
visitor on smartphones and and when I
talk about a pack market which which
somewhere a pack has around 16 countries
and in in 16 countries India is the
fifth fifth largest digital spend and
already and we have got to be the number
one of course in ends of time but when
overall you can see this is a seven
point four billion ad industry out of
which will person is digital as of now
rest is all the TV print out those radio
so but but here on here we are making a
of large advances in terms of how much
we spend if you see the old image here
it talks about 2015 versus 2020 so in
2015 we were about print 13% for in 2020
we will be about 26% of media budgets
only on digital right so this is this is
what we are expecting that's why it is
are there like you buy is all gonna move
to digital like a golden time for you
guys to move in this mmm this world
because it's growing crease and this
will increase maybe in the next five to
ten years
so with tier two tier three people are
k23 see users audiences coming on
sparkles the number of smartphones and
Internet users India being one of the
you know populous country in the world
second-largest and then also democratic
countries so we we will be the number
one democratic country which will have
maximum smartphone users soon enough so
causing us
and the numbers like this stands as
they'll run a few so it's about 1.3
million won for 1300 million which is
1.3 billion population with active
entities users of 460 million and so
many so many mobile users because group
is being one of the easy way out for
your multiple people to access internet
so mobile usage will increase and it
that's why you see a lot of these people
and lot of the Chinese plans coming in
and advertising a lot of spending a lot
of money because they know the
potentials in in the country stands will
be where we will be spending a lot of
money buying smartphones and then
accessing Internet through smartphones
so so when we have smartphones what do
we do right but what what to what
absolutely go on so we go primarily on
on on our social platforms right so you
look at your friends you look at your
family what do they do with it they go
on Instagram or Facebook or YouTube
Linden or tumblr or snapchat all of
these applications and all smart
applications which means they're all all
on their phones and you access them when
you get a smart phones and now when you
go on these applications what is the
source of money through which Facebook
or YouTube is owning so they are only
moving through advertisements which
means that as the only way these
companies are growing and Google and
Facebook being one of the Bureau of
quick companies to gain a lot of money
and become almost to the world famous
companies that they are right now
there's only because of advertising
so with the tool that they have and and
a lot of people that that visit these
website they're able to make a lot of
money in this advertising
so how can we you know improve the
behavior of of when you see ads or how
can we improvise on the ads that you see
so now many would you like on the
website like scoop scoop and your VTP
dent and being Indian and all of these
websites you will see that the articles
that they take a word or they actually
cover about a you know millennion
audience talking about travel talking
about
um maybe maybe maybe all the topics that
we that we think about they they write
about it and then when when one instance
come in where you have a trip to you
know five places to visit when you're
given your 25 and then you read that
article and on the right hand side you
will see that there is an ad which talks
about a trip to trip to Bali or there is
an ad which talks about a trip to you
know island so how is that then when you
are reading an article which is
contextually talking about the content
talks about travel you see an ad which
is also talking about trouble which
means that we have personalised that we
are we are using the euro keywords we
are using the behavior of you are the
person and then showing you add similar
to your interest which is what
personalization also is that now when we
learn that you are a person who is
looking for a gym membership so then we
know that you are all already looking
for or or fitness or you're a fitness
person then we show you ads which are
related fitness so we are moving away
from just showing any random add to any
random person we are talking about
showing the right ad to the right person
at the right time with the right message
so with all these right things where we
move towards the next level of marketing
which is personalization and all of
these brands when we talk about the
plans like your Microsoft IBM sales TCS
or any of these big brands that they
have the big IT companies that we have
even those guys when they send you an
email they've talked about
personalization so they do not say that
either we have this to offer this is the
price this is this no they say hi Rohan
hope you are doing well Tim what are you
looking for what can you help you with
so it's all very you know personalized
to me as a as a person so they try and
make sure that their interaction with me
there they they make it more sound like
it sits
personally and just to be and not to
thousands of people so that's that's
personalization and order these are
filters that help us in making sure that
we are more personalized so we take out
behavior of people to take our
demographic of people what Kate gender
category they fall under what it does do
do they have what kind of things that
you buy so on Amazon when you go and buy
you know if you're buying anything from
a pen to to a laptop we know about it so
that's that's also what we use when
Amazon targets you again with some
compact and then we know what what email
that you you know get or what call
center have you called upon so all of
these things are just fun other
wave whatever your interest what is the
you know pocket that you call
who the moving away from that which is
more about what career options in what
salary to you what can you expect and
epsilon I was saying prior or the runner
has already covered what exactly the
fields are for you to take you know your
first step in digital marketing which
could be a co alien but if you'll ask me
I I would not recommend anybody to go on
SEO with the kind of introduction you
gave early on around what how many years
experience most of you have so you have
good number of experience even if it's
two years three years seven years ten
years they will go for a nice view of is
what I will tell you because the SEO is
more about manual tasks equal powers you
know you know daily basis it retainers
you you you you do a workers job so I
would not recommend any of you when you
already have experience to go for it
rather go for an STM job which is search
engine marketing which could be a Google
page search or could be a Facebook to
sort of with a lot of you are asking
about you know how to be a social how to
be a strategist not started since system
one who's whose goal expertise is not
about execution his core expertise is
not about of which which tools to use
it's about what brand really wants
whether the brand water and wants what
so within it you look at what is the
brand currently perceived as among
people and then you try and change that
perception that's what it started just
will do so you do need to have expertise
of any of these fields to be honest
where you have to be a strategist but
you need a lot of expertise is you need
to have the right set of mind when
you're planning for a brand to change
the perception in terms of users or
their audience so it's like you go
shopping right you go shopping you buy
products by you
lot of you buy groceries as well right
so when you buy groceries
why do you take one product versus why
do you not take the other product so
when you are buying a you know
toothpaste for example why don't you why
do you take a incident versus a Colgate
versus or you know now even a conjuring
is there so why why would you choose one
over the other what made that perception
it's the brand messaging that made the
perception of a person that we will buy
this because this has called this is
this has not sold this has calcium
other's hands no calcium whatever but
that's actually the brand manager or the
strategist who has thought about it that
what will the person think when he goes
to the grocery shop very wise the the
toothpaste that's more what makes the
end decision for a user to change the
mind because he remembers that the brand
says that it's not let's say it's on
ammonia it sits with ammonia or it's not
with ammonia so these are small things
that we note and then we say okay
whether or not we go for this product so
that's a sadist
role which is not here because that's a
role which comes from within
it does not can it cannot be taught to
anyone it's it's how you how you work
how you do a normal day-to-day work how
you choose products how you choose
things is what makes your strategies and
how you can change the perceptions on
one thing to the other world for the
brand but it's what we feed up out of
poverty expectations or different rules
so a person who is a pressure you know
pressure with SEO a pressure with a cm
at atmosphere in market you can expect
this job I have my you know colleagues
whose brothers and sisters just got into
digital marketing so I ignore a factor
it's about anywhere like two to four
lakhs is what you are expected to get
when you start your journey whether it's
a internship that you're looking for
whether it's a you know first executed
dog that you're looking for as a
pressure and that's the expectations you
should at least go for two to four lakhs
opportunity
the below that will not motivate you to
remove to be in that will be in that
role and and Delhi I was I would really
uh give before this so I noticed that in
Delhi you have hundreds of agencies who
look for anybody who has experience with
SEO and SEM and that's when you have
experience with both those you know
things which is SEO and SEM you can go
for a digital mass marketing manager
bill in a start-up where you cannot
expect this much salary but then yeah in
an ER in a small agency you can expect
the salary of you know close to six to
ten laps depending on what what what
clients do they have so that's that's
the expectation social media again
something which which will involve a lot
of creativity you can get close to three
to seven lakhs copywriter which involves
you know write eighty ads or writing
messages on social group on social media
or on soldiers that can again get you
anywhere from three to six acts whether
your pressure or maybe low key is
experience
okay I'll pick up a couple of questions
here how much does an NBA pressure would
Cohen if she is if she goes for it does
not matter whether you remember your
heart because when you go for a D it's
you again so graduate who does not have
BA degree it doesn't really make any
difference because you do not study DMS
MBA at most probably because I don't
think any MBAs or privity F specialist
special speciality as such so it's it's
the same thing whether you're mvvm all
you are a catch weight so you would
expect the same awning which is
mentioned mostly here but if you want to
be very specific to what rolls then I
can give you more details around it
but if you check your profiles they
expect you to be a pro at TM for
strategies of course they will of course
they will ask you to be expert in
anything and everything so I am NOT an
expert in everything right but I have
done well myself so imagine if you are
good enough you can do well whether your
job description C strategies or not or
she says that you need to be experienced
by things nothing really have to be that
way
but if you want to be more specific just
let me know which
the programmatic required programming
knowledge no not not at all
it does not need any programming
knowledge I personally do not have any
programming skills but I am a head of
programmatic or one of the largest
companies in the world in an agency of
course
you don't need to be any unit you don't
need to know any language so I did my
computers Computer Science Engineering
which means that I know all languages
back then I used to know all languages
but now I do not know any language I
don't remember even a single html5 code
as well but it does not matter because
you don't need that there are different
tools when you require automatic
advertising and that's the future of
next ten years so it involves AI it
involves a lot of other automation tools
you start career as freelancer hos DMC
okay so uh Sophie Lancer you don't
really have to have a career right if
you love Philippa that's the thing if
you're a freelancer you don't have a
career if you if you have to get married
and you say you're a freelancer oh you
don't have a player okay so know it when
you say you are going to be a
freelancers there is no there is nothing
you need to have you just need to go out
there find your first client pitch it to
them that you can do digital for them
and just take it that's it and fit in a
cup I am still in Starbucks and and do
digital marketing pure in all aspects so
you don't need to baby so when when
somebody asks me like what do you what
do we do when we do a course right we
you have done a course right go you go
to your closest friends and family
whoever business if nobody has a
business then start your own business
which is you are doing freelancing now
when you start a business here - you do
cold-calling right you do you reach out
to almost everybody who you know and
tell them that you will be do a Facebook
marketing for them you will do SEO for
them you will do SCM for them and just a
lender you will charge maybe five
thousand and whatever next comes in
impact when you get just five thousand
but is that guy or that business even
gets bunting Lee of that activity that
you have done in digital marketing you
earn yourself a badge of anything that
you want to call this list you can't
give auto call yourself growth hacker
mobile yourselves that because growth
hacker just means that you are getting
business for somebody else so if you can
get one single client for your you know
friend or family or anyone then you can
call yourself Kronecker as long as you
can get that one single client out of
the air how does the Tractatus on start
engine seven by giving strategy right
when meet a strategist if you call
yourself a strategist what do you do you
prepare a strategy for the brand you
tell them that this is what you do and
if you do this you will get 5% extra in
the business that you get so that's
that's the strategy that you have given
if it works that create if it fails then
bad you own beats is the strategy that
you give being an interviewer what
already skills do you look for an
interview I hire for all digital aspects
but then yes what qualities will I look
for see anybody can do a Google course
any because it's free of course if you
want to do a Google certificate it does
not require any cost so if somebody
tells me that I have done there is not
done this I suppose ask them technical
questions like what is the CTR what it's
impressions go to click throughs what is
the conversion how you inflate
conversion pixels and all of these
cushions that you might get but then if
that person is able to answer those
questions good the next thing that you
need to know is that yes or no so if
it's a yes that's good that means
technically that person knows now second
question will be are you have you done
something on freelancing or maybe or
your own project have you done something
have you move opened a website are you
doing logging are you doing leaguer if
you have a Facebook page
these are very common questions that we
will be asked will you say you're a
digital marketing expert and people who
are experienced especially people over
five or seven years experience for you
it will be even more difficult difficult
you are saying that you are able to
switch a job switching is not easy and
switching career is or even more
difficult so you have to be very very
specific you can mold your current you
know whatever skills that you have into
digital skills by just enhancing those
skills in your personal you know
entrepreneurship that you can do with
basically you can start a blog you can
start a new class and you can you can
say that I want I want to start my own
Facebook page all of these pages which
is your being Indian array of X so all
of these started by some on persons they
did not have a team now
I have a team right so they even make
better content but anybody of you any
single individual of you can create your
own Facebook page and start you know
gaining attraction our or or our users
just because the content that you force
is good so do that and you can call
yourself an expert
which sector is good for pressure
complete your question piece I do not
have an MBA but master's in journalism
from India's number one journalism
school seminaries experienced two
international publications I have
publications I now work as manager of
content strategy for phone number to get
browser which Ripper Ripper web browser
a bit better is it fre what word browser
where where I fall in this list because
according to UT 1mb college is important
who says that I never said it it's M be
connected if you do it again or if you
do a graduation you are the same person
if you do digital marketing I never did
an MBA so and even today nobody asked me
whether you have done an MBA or not once
you get somewhere like once you start
your digital marketing journey its teh
experience in how much money have you
spent or your crimes right that's that's
what matters no no degrees matter in
this course
you
and if I have to tell you who you fit in
you will fit in here
content marketing managers
okay I'm working as a Sales Coordinator
as well as here in consultant infinity
Co company after his experience got my
the Optima BTech degree so I want to
move into VM how much value can expect
in this market depends on whether you go
as inexperienced or you go as a pressure
if you go is a pressure to lux if you as
an experienced six locksmith
talking in terms of salary strategist
salary strategist below and more than
anybody else so you can expect a salary
of 10 to 15 lakhs
also strategy specialist coordinators
they are same yes they are mostly same
they're just a fancy way ways to call
one says anything
we got regardless of the fact that they
do the same job
I completed my MBA from Cardiff I work
in intercept HP HSBC back-end booking
and real estate
um PLC is a file which feels should I go
for C in sales if you want to go for
sales do digital sales if you want to
open you just want to change your page
profile right and you want to still
count your sales experience go for
digital sales and in the process of
going for digital sales you will learn
all almost everything in digital that
will be the first best way to you know
change options change paths career path
so I've already answered that question
dog
Paulo when you say that people who are
experienced get hired that the same
thing I told you reach out to pull Paulo
reach out to your friends reach out to
your family
come on look you who you can trust
whatever as a business start doing
digital marketing for them and the next
time you give an interview you tell that
you are already doing digital marketing
for this com.com and.com
that's the only way you can you can
compete with somebody who already has
experience or already is Anton in the in
the industry
and there is no requirement for MBA Tier
one colleges
there is no requirement from there
currently I'm booking as a PDF with two
Oh
the to word
I want to know the full service agency
book and I okay it's a funny story but
gosh I when I thought when when I went
to an agency for the first time after
going to the agency I started my own
agency it's funny things but when you go
into an agency you feel it what are they
doing we can do the same thing and even
better and on everything process but it
doesn't work that way so when they bill
you think that you can open an agency
lick if you really want to open an
agency all of these things are what you
do which is back in this slide
all of this
right all of this is what you need to do
plus you need to know program
programming languages as well because
all of this requires you to connect your
people or your cause you know marketing
to the clients with Syed which means
that you should have a technical person
who understands PHP language or or or
some website language so that the code
implementation for an SEO or for a web
design or or any of these things the
code the conversion pixels or
remarketing pixels on any of the pixels
is DD so these are all things that you
will be asked for if you to a full
services agency work
what is digital sales can you please
elaborate so digital sale is basically
sales sales for climbs that you can give
our company off for social media your
company offers SEO your company offers
web design so all of these things are
what you're going to be selling so that
for example you go to a shopkeeper and
you tell him see you are very good the
way you're updating your business but
you can update your business also in
Amazon right you can also operate your
own website and then get customers for
your auto shop so moving away from a
brick and motar
shop into the into the online world
that's digital sales so you have to
convince people to move your businesses
to online and then when you move
businesses online you have to have these
so light for example when you open a
shop you need a you need a you know
outdoor coding sort of a thing to tell
people that this is a new shop which is
clothing which sells groceries or
whatever and the same way when you open
a website you need to tell people that
this is the website through all of these
channels so that that's what the digital
sales person will do educating the
client and then getting business for the
company in terms of whatever they want
to do enter in whether it's SEM or SEO
if you are already in pain they will
they they will not consider you to be
pressured because you have the skills of
doing sales and you yourself have the
skills right so why will you call
yourself pressure don't call yourself
pressure if you are di
don't undermine yourself in any way when
you do sales because you can do digital
sales or hot PDM for that matter
of course together so when you say you
have a PD and experience of two years
and you want to be a digital specialist
a specialist takes years right a
specialist now when I have to call
somebody specialist he or she should
have experience of maybe four or five
years so obviously is that for five
years you'll start from a lower package
but you then go and get better packages
right so but it depends on what would
package you're currently on so if you're
if currently and already at ten labs and
you now want to go to digital marketing
you would obviously be getting a three
or four labs which will but it will not
be an Apple to Apple comparison when you
say that oh I was running the personal I
am putting this much so you may get
demotivated by it but think before you
want to change it if you redo you know
put in that extra effort of learning
digital marketing in the next take two
wheels then you can go back to the same
package that where you are
I'm a fresher I want to start my Korean
in faith which sector is good all of
these sectors of odia dictionary sectors
are good whichever whichever one you
will UN which which interest you so ask
yourself this question whether you are a
writer whether you can write whether you
can design or whether you can put on
tools if you answer these simple
question to yourselves you can decide
which field you want to go to
well this is good no none of it is bad
or bad to start with
can you advise on which positions could
I start with this product marketing
roller help roll will be helpful when
you say product marketing put is mean by
that product marketing could be you're
building a product
can we get these slide shared with us I
think you will get a video as well so
you will have these slides
we will commence
they are panda she's been very kind
she's like don't and too much time of
yours Rowan Thank You DC here if you
desire below start
ah
if you join executive agencies
organizations are we doing
turning to the pro a training of
absolutely without retraining how can
you know you work so if I I hired really
you know a fresh flow which is official
from from a collision in Jakarta so it's
just been two months and I've been moved
here I have recently locate relocated
here and and I am building a team here
so great so I'm firing as well so when I
hire people you hire because of multiple
reasons right sometimes the attitude
matters sometimes the knowledge matters
sometimes the you know the way you
present your identity or self in
interview matters and sometimes doesn't
anything anything lady does not matter
because something the budget matters
because you don't have the money to hire
that person sometimes there is no there
is no logic to it right because if I'm
hiring it's my personal choice as well a
times that why would I hire somebody
because I think that I can train them
but whenever you are going into an
interview just show that you're
trainable person just make sure that
you're a trainable person which means
that then you would Ross eight to
interview you have to be like I don't
know this right now but I cannot you
know I am open to learning more things
so that's something that you have to
have an attitude about yourself that
will make you mode hireable than any
other capitate so be honest about what
you know what you don't know make sure
that you are trailing everything in a
positive manner and just make sure that
you you convey the right message to
there they're the one who's interviewing
you so I may be coming as you know very
strong over a candidate but ultimately
if a candidate comes very strongly I am
like wow
this bill candidate had on state because
this very overdo it you know what
happened what cushion they lost so
there's so much right when you see all
these even clear and I ask myself do I
really know out of this let me let me
guess so I'll ask myself do I really
know affiliate marketing I would say
maybe with forty person but can I answer
the question if anything comes from your
side yes I can because I am very
confident or whatever I know so that's
that's the thing like you have to be
very confident so you have to make sure
that you're answering everything
correctly and if you don't know just say
I don't know and we are billing this to
learn for audits that you can take up
money is what's really important when
you are starting out right so make sure
that you're not looking for money but
you're looking for an experience an
opportunity so that's something when you
take new projects consider money to be
the last aspect of it take projects run
it spend clients money and see what
results happen that's that's what
digital not rings all about the more
money you spend the better you will
learn because end of the day marketing
is all about spending money
right so that will be all oh nice you
could probably take over and
Hado hon thank you so much it I would
say it is fantastic wonderful and it is
one of the best webinar that I have ever
done I'm so very happy today and it was
so realistic when you were answering all
the questions that I usually shoot it to
me too and handling job assist program
here like when I'm heading the program
your it comes very frequently to me that
if I am from sales background and now I
am going to digital marketing I'm
already getting five lakh six lakh
rupees in han and will I be getting more
in digital marketing it's kind of tough
for me to explain that see you are
actually changing your domain from a
traditional marketing or sales flow to
digital marketing so I'll not be able to
fetch it off for you so just from edenia
so we preach the bridge okay I really
think it doesn't matter how many years
of experience you have what age you have
you know I've trained people who are
even 70 years old and they able to learn
affiliate marketing book or I don't know
what forgot down base in there but then
when you say I want to start as a peel
answer I hope that you can look around
your own be thirty of friends and family
if you don't have anybody who's in the
business they just go out somewhere go
to a shopkeeper just tell him that
whether you whether you would like to
start with Google AdWords you know it's
just how can rookies that they have to
spin thousand rupees is what I end on at
dinner right so that's that's something
that you can just tell somebody that
it's spin thousand rupees and you can
call yourself a freelancer because
that's what it takes to start with
Google AdWords so when you spin that
thousand rupees and you add a coupon of
Google of 2000 and you make it a three
thousand packet and then you will do
advertising for that line even if that
plan gets to customers from it he will
be very happy to spend another thousand
rupees that's how you start your journey
as Africa yes thank you so much thank
you so much Rohan actually I I I would
seriously say that sometimes what
happens is
I take all these questions and I just
feel to say all that but you have
already said this thing that no degrees
actually mattered of one should not
undermine themselves and they are going
for a particular job or the Google
certifications or courses are really
free and anybody can take that but the
major thing is that you should have
practical experience with you and all of
us are really lucky that we are in
simply learn we are taking up the course
in simply done which is already offering
the hands-on experience through projects
I'll just explain you how you can
actually submit your profiles on detour
portents and I would like to first time
Rohan thank you so much for coming
online drone and giving us so much of
insights and it was really fantastic
wonderful session that I attended like
ever it is one of the best sessions
thank you so much Ron I expected we will
most welcome and thanks DC thank you
Roman thank you thanks for your time and
weekend
hi everyone I'm just making you through
that these all are the companies I could
not actually include everything on this
particular slide because we have
approximately 80 to 90 partners on board
it till now as we have started from this
year I'm trying my best to get more and
more partners on board so that I can get
more opportunities for the candidates
who are taking up the course with us and
I believe that we are really lucky that
the most of our candidates are making
through the interviews as well as Rowan
was explaining that no degrees mattered
it is not actually essential to get an
MBA degree from top-notch colleges the
only thing that matters is the
confidence in the technology that you
are learning and that comes through the
projects through the practical work that
you people are doing so I would suggest
you all to complete your projects get it
evaluated get eligible for the job
assist program and the eligibility
includes many things and it depends upon
the projects that you are completing 80%
of the course completion so each and
everything will be in your hands that
you need to submit your profiles on the
job versus photos and I'll assist you
once you submit your profile because it
will automatically be updated in my
database and I'll get all your details
you
okay are you all getting my screen like
I are you all able to see my screen
Thank You Vinay thanks red Rangers Thank
You Manmeet thanks Ambika thank you all
of you thanks kadar so now as I said
that I'm not unable to put all the logos
here but I've tried to do that and
hmm I'll just shake it from now
okay so there are some of the candidates
who got placed and I just tried to
include those two and all of these
people went for the interview and they
were they were offered as kind of good
package or some of the people got ahead
as well because they completed the
course and they showed that practical
experience in their present company so
they got digital marketing the
assignments in their own company as well
as ron was explaining you and how to
submit your profile is something that I
was detailing you that you need to get
your project evaluated you need to have
a final score of 80% and you need to
have completion certificate in hand so
if you are armed seeking for assistance
from outside you must complete your
projects that are there in your course
and submit your profile on the portal
I'll just check if I can show you how to
submit your profile on the portal so
once you click this particular link of
WWE champion
your basis you need to submit your
profile yo can we get sub can't project
evaluated error shake I'm just calling
the concerned person so that he can
answer your question and he is handling
the project evaluation party also just
give me a second
so that I can address your query and I
can resolve it now so that you don't
need to follow it up just give me a
second
hi Nikki
hi-yah hi-yah she uh who's this or a
sick Russy krycek so he has already
paying the equation if you can let us
know that how can we get second predict
evaluated okay so there are five rounds
in spoken of a participant needs to work
on it and we I think received have you
attended our project sufficient classes
no okay surah 60 we have a project of
mention classes on life projects where I
discuss about life projects and I
discuss about stew can mimic pro okay
and even we have a project mentoring
sessions with trainer we'll discuss
about that okay so where we discussed in
detail about how many rounds are there
how you need to work on it why because
weekend is a virtual project is like a
simulation project page you need to work
on it a keyword research is available
over there and it is the ad creation
it's like a case study will be given to
you and I am the one who will be
evaluating this yeah McCune iam you can
see I can provide you I don't know like
I'll do one thing once the session is
done right I'll take your data from here
okay
okay so to get certified life force
manually see if there is a criteria guys
there are online self earning
participants are dead and there are live
classes registered participant okay so
makan are we can do that I'll do one
thing once you are done with the session
right I'll drop your mail on this guy's
I will I share the link on Monday we
have our project condition class which
is conducted by me okay and there is no
results respect let me be very clear on
spookin there is no results it is up it
gives a real-time experience if we
provide you how to work on AdWords how
to create PPC apps okay you need to you
need to you need to do a little bit of
research on how you create ads on PPC
and AdWords ok you need you need to try
to get more number of likes use
impressions for your ads okay this is
the main purpose of this simulation nap
which we are providing if deviously what
happen is there was life project it used
to take a three months time once you
complete the course we used to take all
three months time participant needs to
get their own website then you are yes
Lakshmi this is Musharraf
yes yes Abhishek see those who have
enrolled for live classes let me be very
clear
those have enrolled for life classes
that is sexy pause or digital marketing
specialist program they will be working
on spooky dynamic Pro there are five
rounds okay - can't mimic Pro it's a
case study based project is called as it
is called as a what you say our
simulation project everything will be
dead you just need to select the right
thing at the right place you need to do
a little bit of research to know more
about Adwords Keyword research and PPC
ad creation okay that's the thing and
four who have enrolled for online self
selling program then there is arm flight
projects I think most of the
participants are but it is my session
now today is back a lecture me Francis
is did I think I've shared these things
with all of the participants through
email okay ah once again now is McCune
yeah open I can do that
I don't think once you are done with the
session right I'll call you after tours
okay we can connect on this no worries
okay as your master so ve my yeah I'll
take that we should have thank you so
much time thank you thank you thank you
for coming online and solving the
queries it was instant but thank you so
much for your support thank you thanks
as far as eligibility is concerned yes
um I'll just check I think winner is
they're hoping me okay so yes for
eligibility of applying for the
placement process yes you need to
complete your masters you need to get
the certification in hand as I was
explaining that there is the eligibility
criteria that you need to complete your
projects if you have and you need to get
80 percent and you need to apply for the
four job assistance and you need to
upload your profile and the thing is
that if you have completed your projects
it gives us assurance that you have
hands-on experiences well thank you so
much and I was just showing you how to
submit your profile on the job portal so
you just need to submit your profile
from here
log in and answer all the questions I
believe that there is some connection
problem here I am NOT able to get in ok
I got it and then you just need to click
to in drawl and answer the questions it
is approximately 14 patients I will not
take much of your time on weekend I will
just show you quickly that you just need
to enter your course and then you just
need to say that you have already
competed your certification because you
need to have certification in hand I
have certificate from your side mam
diksha
ok dick sure so you can actually submit
your profile as I'm just detailing you
if you have already submitted your
profile I will get it in my database
uploaded so it automatically gets
updated in my database and I'll just
definitely check it here you need to
enter your first name so I as I am
saying that it would be approximately 10
to 11 questions that you need to answer
and through this you just need to enter
all your answers once you update the
last question will be uploading your
resume so you need to upload a file from
your system and it will automatically
get uploaded and will be available with
me in my database whenever I get any
requirements from any of the company I
just read for my database so that I can
there for which particular profile is
best suitable so that I can forward it
to the company according to the
requirement
sometimes the requirements are really
kind of mixture in which they ask for
all kinds of domains that we have
learned today so I just need to check
that what is your expertise level in
that if you have some traditional
background again I am saying that
traditional marketing order a sales
background I might not be able to fetch
a job which will give you more than your
present salary just because you might be
considered as a fresher for digital
marketing in that that company on other
hand if you are able to
really answer all their technical
equations they might take you on higher
salary just because they at the
background doesn't matter in that case
as Rowan was describing that if you are
really really great if you have
expertise in a particular technology and
you are able to answer if you are really
able to address all the queries in your
interview you will be taken ahead in
that so I think I am clear as far as
eligibility is concerned and the job
requirements that are coming to me is
concerned if you have any queries you
can drop me your queries ad job assist
ad simply learn dotnet I am just typing
it here for your reference if you have
any queries related to job assets do
drop me an email so that I can address
your equations online and you need to
upload your profile so that it can be
available with me and I can refer your
profile once I get the requirements
so thank you so much all of you if you
have any queries from me you can ask you
can just bring me the question so again
I can address that can you provide
resume is simple or guide about what to
mention and how in resume which is good
way oh yeah sure
rustic I will do that you can just bring
me once on email so that I can forward
you the templates thanks Mon Meade I can
forward you the template so that you can
see that how you can put a different
experience levels in the sections of
your ratio I always suggest all my
learners that you have your own
experience and you want to build your
resume according to the experience level
that you have so I cannot actually make
your resume but I can definitely assist
you by forwarding you some of good
templates so that you can refer you need
to put in your section and how you can
make it more impressive because this
will be your first introduction to the
company so when I am forwarding your
resume a it shows that what all
technologies you have covered so I
always say that you need to highlight
your technologies in this skill section
that you have in your resume it do not
drop it and as I said rustic you can
drop me one email so that I can forward
you the templates as well thanks to
tranche thanks Abby shake how can we be
in communication forge or business as I
said that you can drop me an email and
here also you can see job assist at
simply ENCOM you can anytime ping me on
that and I will revert you back with the
answers thanks the sick I've got your
email thank you thanks Rashmi thank you
all of you thanks Abhishek thank you for
being online so I believe that we were
able to provide you all the solutions
today and it was fantastic session for
me and I hope that it was really
wonderful for you all also thank you for
your presence and we will be taking more
and more webinars in hand of this kind
so that we can provide you more insight
it was so nice recipe thank you for
your input thank you be fresh have a
nice weekend all of you thank you
[Music]